now people around the world will be
watching the skies this weekend
as a big chinese rocket is set to plunge
back to earth
it's still not known exactly when or
where it will come down
but chinese authorities say the risk of
danger is low
this chinese rocket may be in an
uncontrolled free-fall
the 21-ton spacecraft took off last week
carrying a core module of china's future
space station into orbit
it was the first of 11 missions needed
to complete the project
now the rockets could become one of the
largest objects ever to plunge back to
earth
chinese officials say most of it will
burn up in the atmosphere
and is very unlikely to put anyone in
danger
as far as i know this type of rocket has
a special technical design
and most of its components will be
destroyed and disappear during the
reentry process
the likelihood of causing harm to
aviation or people on the ground is
extremely low
the relevant government departments will
promptly report the situation to the
public
some experts have criticized china
saying the rocket's re-entry is out of
control
they say potentially dangerous debris
could escape incineration
and that it's impossible to say for sure
where exactly it will land
it's not uncommon for spacecraft to fall
back to earth
sometimes even causing damage but the
sheer size of this one
is keeping the international space
community on alert
commanders we're now joined by tim flora
head of the space degree office at the
european
space agency in darmstadt germany is it
normal for such
big rockets to re-enter the earth's
atmosphere and
how dangerous is that
yes we see usually space debris
returning to earth
uh regularly every year about 150 tons
of space debris
come down and this is about 75 percent
of the space degree that is an
orbit uh overall now
this particular event is now a
a very large object you said already
it's around 20
metric tons that's subject to this
uncontrolled reentry
later this evening or this night and
when we look back in history there's
only one this is the main flight of this
particular type of launch system about
one year ago
since about 1990 that came down of this
size class
to back to so how exactly can you
calculate how much of the rocket is
going to burn up and
where possible debris will land
for for estimating whether fragments uh
doing
that can result from the destructive
re-entry process in the atmosphere so
the terminal and mechanical stress
that the upper stage uh will make to
fragment
we need model and we need to design
information on on the upper stage and
for this type
we here don't have that information so
we can only
use information from from other launch
types
launch systems and there from from the
very large ones
up to 20 percent of the mars in
particular those components with
high melting points materials could
reach ground
so could survive the re-entry so this is
a smaller fraction of the entire mass
and we follow up the decay with uh
with the radars on ground and from that
we can predict the evolution
of the orbit to the decay process and
then we can project this on on the
earth of the earth surface and maybe
as you correctly said the uncertainty
shrink down later during the day and
then we can
make better predictions
okay there are critics that say that
chinese rockets do not meet
international standards
how responsible are chinese authorities
in the field of space travel
as i said already we don't have the
design information for this particular
type of rocket available
so it's very difficult to assess this
without having this but what i can say
for sure
that in the frame of international
collaboration that is key
to tackle the problem of space debris we
very successfully
work with chinese colleagues also
particularly in the frame of the
interagency debris coordination
committee
where we define the mitigation
guidelines so
this is working well on the other hand
we see of course
um that a higher number of launch
systems
these days make controlled re-entries
but this is still a number of about 20
and that's the fact today okay tim flora
head of the space debris office at the
european space agency in darmstadt
germany thank you
you